Serious Questions...spoiler alert!
In Jurassic Park,
was Nedry under some kind of a deadline to get those embryos smuggled out because otherwise
why choose the night of a tropical storm with tourists on the island for the first time, dude?
You control the whole park. Take a rain check, try again tomorrow. So you crashed your Jeep in a ravine
Take a mulligan, Newman
"Hello, John" Would the real John Hammond have had to interact with himself every single time tourists did the automatic tour ride?
"John, that hurt."
It only works if he's talking to himself. Did he have to hire a staff of John Hammond impersonators? *gasp*
Did they clone John Hammond?
So what happens if you pay a visit to Jurassic Park and no dinosaurs show up?
You know, kind of like what happened with the test group
Do you get a refund? Do you get a rain check? And why are all of the dinosaur cages so packed with foliage?
It's a zoo. Don't you want people to see them? To see or not to see. That is the question
In Lost World, wouldn't you need a lot of permits before putting a dinosaur zoo in San Diego?
He says they're planning to open in like less than a month. The city council really signed off on this?
Roland the game hunter has a single earring on his right ear
Is this the closest we'll come to gay representation in the franchise?
Or does it count that all the dinosaurs are bred to be female and still start families together?
Why was Jeff Goldblum's daughter cut from the gymnastics team school cut you from the team?
I'd like to see Simone Biles kick a raptor through a window
Hey in Jurassic Park 3, what was Dr. Grant's first name again? ALAN. Oh, yeah
This is T-rex pee?
-Where'd you get it?
-You don't want to know.
I've got a theory. Let a t-rex piss on you. Release the t-rex pee tape
Shouldn't Alan be more concerned about those 3 Pteranodons flying toward the mainland at the end
I can't bring a papaya back from Hawaii, but the flying lizard monsters get a pass
So in Jurassic world, we're supposed to believe that the general population is bored with Dinosaurs
I mean people still go to zoos, right? It's not like little kids get bored with tigers and monkeys and stuff
What happened to Isla Sorna, it's a whole other dinosaur island
Are we just gonna pretend that Lost World and Jurassic Park 3 never happened? Yes
So they designed a new dinosaur to boost attendance and yet they made it invisible
IT CAN CAMOFLAUGE!
How am I taking a selfie with that?
So these gyrospheres can be piloted off the rails by guests around the entire park?!
They're rolling into restricted areas and I can't even take one freakin shopping cart out of the Whole Foods parking lot
Okay, Fallen Kingdom. You're telling me they built a theme park on an island with an active volcano
Twice. That is a really big oversight. If you're gonna spare no expense, maybe hire a geologist
Jimmy Fallon
Why didn't Dr. Ian Malcolm testify for the Senate lying across the table with his shirt unbuttoned? That seems a lot more like his style.
It's now been two movies of people talking about sending dinosaurs into war zones
And we haven't seen one armored dinosaur eating terrorists
When are we gonna get to the fireworks factory and buy fireworks factory? I mean a Dino riders movie
So, how do I get invited to a black-market dinosaur auction? Is there a mailing list? Is there a secret handshake?
Do we do orgy mass? I'm just trying to get the feel here
Four million dollars seems awfully cheap for a live dinosaur then again
How do you even start to set a baseline price for a dinosaur?
Do you just check what Tigers are selling for and add a couple of zeros?
What would a slovenian arms dealer want with a personal murder dinosaur?
What kind of operation is this guy running where a raptor would be better than like a guy with a gun?
He wants to assassinate a rival via Raptor attack?! Well, I guess it would send a message
And that message is that I am this completely responsible...
Also after your Raptor finishes killing its target, how do you get her back into her cage
We never saw a signal for go back home and don't kill me or anyone else or get noticed by the cops
It's gonna be in part three
So when the little girl lets all the dinosaurs out at the end, that's basically murder, right? Yes
After two movies do we actually know anything about Owen Grady or is played by Chris Pratt enough of the character trick?
I don't know. He likes vests
Could Rocky beat up a dinosaur?
Yeah, I could
Subscribe.